[Music]
the teacher who most inspired me is dr.
Lundy anatomic Kenneth Johnson
meaningful panin Richard with Norman
Cohen financial Rex and Phillips Don
Roberts Judy Baldwin pens down she
changed my life and I would not be
sitting here without her
so Mary Jake my whole life has been
surrounded by arts educators
[Music]
why does Crum deserve this honor a
better question is why doesn't she
Rachel gives her heart and soul to her
job to her kids to the world she's
inspired me to be more brave with what I
do I wouldn't be Who I am today if it
wasn't for her Crump has changed my
entire life my philosophy and teaching
theater is that it should be student
driven the students you know they tell
me I've made an impact on them but the
impact they have made on me is profound
I learned how to be human from them they
have had the greatest impact on me truly
[Music]
you